but you know what is no laughing matter
what confronting your fears and that is
where we begin with our series never too
late where Gail Tony Vlad and I tried to
show you that it's never too late to try
something new I set out recently to
prove that it's never too late to
confront that fear that I have of
heights I mean I have a serious serious
fear of heights and it's something that
I've wanted to tackle for quite some
time the US Army was kind enough to help
arrange a therapy session what you might
call a bit of exposure therapy
[Music]
it's sunrise at the U.S Army's parachute
team Annex along North Carolina Southern
border and the soldiers have been awake
for hours
and so have I any last words I'll see
you when I hit the ground if you see the
anxiety written all over my face it
might be because I was questioning just
what in the hell I had gotten myself
into please welcome Nate Burleson
do want to jump out of a plane though
because I am afraid of heights with a
parachute yeah listen with the parents
of course but maybe I was partially to
blame telling everyone about my fear of
heights you're going to get there you
think CBS Morning is not going to ask
you to jump off a bridge the last ounce
of comfort I carried with me this
morning was the fact that my caretakers
were the US Army's parachute team the
golden knights I want to be advised the
winds are 8-15 can you relay after the
jumpers
these men and women of our armed forces
have completed thousands of jumps
all around the world tomorrow I will be
jumping out of a plane
tomorrow
responsible son I still needed to call
mom and dad you're gonna be on
somebody's neck you're not gonna be by
yourself right yeah Mom this is my first
time ever doing it of course I'm not
gonna be by myself yeah I'll be attached
to somebody okay all right all right
yeah okay how do you feel about it I'm
nervous my I have some anxiety I have a
real fear of heights you know I don't
like being
um up too high
yeah I'm doing it with the pros
when you land
just
protect your mother okay your toes are
going to go over the edge
you're going to squat down like a
baseball catcher for me ready set Arch
exact position I want you if you put
your feet down before me
I'm gonna ride you in like a surfboard
man there's nothing I can do for you
after an extensive classroom safety
lesson we are going to say Ready Set
Arch on the commander Arch I am throwing
us out of that airplane a review of our
gear
[Music]
it was time to roll it's going down baby
the Army booked us a few seats aboard
their twin otter turbo prop are you
nervous
I think
it's more nervous playing football
I was more nervous my first day on TV
not as nervous as Tony dancing or Adele
singing
I feel good I feel at home
I'm with my peoples
I was real cool on the ground
that little heart is starting to flutter
right now
sitting feet from an open airplane door
two and a half miles above the ground
with a parachute strapped to your back
that humbles you pretty quickly my last
words are
your mind
do anything
remember it's never ever ever too late
you got this
cause I got this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Free Fall lasted just over a minute
but during the fall time seemed to stand
still
[Music]
foreign
that's awesome my brother thanks for
being a great passenger damn that was
crazy
that was crazy I'm not gonna lie to you
at that door
ask some second thoughts
he pushed me I said let's do this oh man
it's never too late to conquer your
fears I had a fair Heights I don't think
I'll do any more you have my phone
let me see if my mom's awake yeah I'm
okay I'm okay it was amazing
it was it was amazing I I don't know how
to explain it
really deep yeah yeah I had tears in my
eyes when I hit the ground
now you know what's crazy like as much
adrenaline that was running through me
when we initially jumped fear
overwhelmed me for a second and then it
was really peaceful but then like as I
started to come down
I immediately missed being higher up the
closer I got to the ground I want to go
back up
and Tony the windows bravo bravo nade
bravo I believe that that was the most
transformative thing that I've ever done
just one single act
um it just did something to me once I
was in the air and when I hit the ground
like I said immediately I wanted to get
back on the plane and jump again you
really did you really did but fear over
speeding just watching you do it that
shot when you're when they're talking
you're talking your camera is there
somebody else there with you or is there
are you holding a stick there's a guy
waiting outside on the wing and he is
trained to just watch you and film you
as we are so he's coming down with you
yes now does it seem like you're just
falling at a high rate of speed that's
another thing it doesn't seem fast at
all it seems like you're floating down
to earth and it's it's wild because in
the morning I didn't eat I wanted my
bladder to be empty I didn't want
anything to happen any action was to
happen in there I didn't know how much
did you wear an adult diaper I should
have yeah but everything was empty out
of me but here's what about your body
and here's the thing about fear when I
was wasn't that plane and started to
duck walk to that door my body was
giving me every signal to walk back yeah
it was telling me Nate you have to go to
the bathroom you have to go pee right
you have to throw up you have to
everything every excuse and I had to
ignore it and I think that's the biggest
thing I learned about fear your body
will tell you one thing it's your heart
and your mind that has to overcome it
yeah courage is facing your fear and
doing it anyway Tony decopo I know you
saw what you think
I was very impressed you know I had I
had a general feeling that the jump had
gone okay because Nate should work the
next day
that was good news that's true
I like that you called your mom said
it's a good surprise that he had a fear
of heights because this is a guy this is
a guy with a vertical Leaf that's out of
the building so I was surprised he was
frightened to be up there but then to go
back to Gail's point about the adult
diapers maybe it's because I'm in a
playroom and I'm surrounded by
children's diapers
totally dry on the ground I was dry
tears yeah because I love the reaction
from your mom yes I love your reaction
me too I love that you called the rice
yeah of course shout out to my mom Mrs
Burleson he's okay all right Brad what
do you got all right so tomorrow in our
series never too late I learn all about
Japanese
swordsmanship girl I watch this very
nice very great for your first time I'm
stopped
maybe it does
so I set out to learn the history of the
samurai sword and how to master it
that's happening tomorrow on CBS
mornings it's not as exciting to jump it
out of a plane or singing no it is
exciting artist but it's a it's a path
of personal growth I'm excited about it
Blair I can't wait and I think we're
going to learn something and I always
always with my stories I always like
that when that happens only you bled
only